interesting men are ashamed for not
dating overweight women but women will
say all day like oh he needs to make
this much money he used to be this tall
that i don't know i'll just let someone
let let's not get started
let's listen let's not get started let's
hear it but let's let's not know
we shouldn't
yeah it doesn't i mean instagram if you
have a lot of followers it does pay the
bills but vbr doesn't come live
do you know anyways next question
a bbl would you guys rather have a girl
with a smaller butt that's natural
natural or a bbl 110 natural natural
natural natural because if we're growing
older than our ceo your your thing's
just melting
why just why
nah man
say why is he dripping like no way like
bro you know like girls now that you be
bills you know how much you have to go
to gym and how much you have to get
checkups for when you're 65 you're still
going to get checkups bro come on bro
how do you how do you know i didn't even
know this
yeah yeah more than like 5.99
the reason i know that one's because
i don't want to see your name i don't
want to get canceled
you could just hate a girl
there was a female that was a youtuber
and obviously naturally she kind of had
but then
she then got used her fat from her
stomach into her
what was that the liposuction yeah but
then she then got a bbl and then she
became botched but it was like
she has to go to gymnastics to maintain
it and she goes through all these
healthy conditions and that because of
it and it's like when like obviously
cool you had a few roles in there but
it's like you could have still went gym
now you have to go to jail because you
have no choice because if you don't go
gym you're going to die what about like
what about like what about like fake
boobs is it the same
it is the same
just leave it just you look like nah
just be natural just be natural
you know i think there's a there's a
very big difference between what you
actually want and what you like to see
yeah i mean like
like obviously big breasts whatever
whatever i like when you see it on the
road on the street like yeah you might
broad
brandon he's a brother it's a brother
that's holding it in place like that
and you know your fantasizing whatever
you like yeah cool but you don't
actually want that do you mean like when
i'm at home i don't want this
you're blowing up in your face i don't
need that i don't want that you would
want canyon
it depends it's a lot of what you need
versatile like what you just like to
look at social media change like the
perspective of what some men
looking
for girls these days i think
yeah true i think it's because we're
coming into a digital age now where a
lot of things on social media are
actually affecting their lives
and all that yeah
especially since clovid because everyone
just shifted online
because no one was outside everyone was
like go online like do you know what
do you guys think that social media um
gave unrealistic standards more for men
or for women
and men men men men would have to be a
boss
yeah you have to make money in like all
that yeah definitely definitely men like
sometimes it's like oh when you get into
our argument
and he doesn't send you like 300 pounds
and he's not the one like what
and the thing is girls actually start
believing that
i actually stopped believing that like
no no we just argued
of course we would we know you
know do you do you feel like most girls
think they're hotter than they are 100
110 yes
yes 100
they stems from their friends 100 yeah
bro um
this i know girls are bad you know your
friend is media
you guessed him as soon as you let's get
into argument or a fight you are ugly
anyways like bro no no no no but like
i don't know it's not in terms of like
reassurance because some girls don't
need that but if guys aren't
giving them the kind of look you know i
mean it it kind of does boost a bit of
confidence
you're not going to marry a godo
you don't know that well
but anyways like sometimes girls we like
we lie to each other though like i've
been to a point where i was i would say
like i was overweight right because
after college um i stopped playing
sports and it just caught up to me like
really fast and i ended up losing it but
like oh my god my friends have gassed me
up so much and i'd be like no i'm fat oh
they'll be like you're fake
that's the thing you see with us boys
here like
bro like there'll be times that a guy
could get a trim like i could get a trim
that was the time i got a trim i was
feeling it
my boy sorry you know like bro
who's nicer you know what i mean what's
kinder to someone telling them the truth
or telling them what they want to hear
i think foster depends on your
relationship as well
from a distance i'm gonna tell you look
good you know but if it's my friend
friend i'm gonna take [ __ ] up like
let's pick a different one still i feel
like i fall out for guys
i feel like for guys guys can take more
criticism than girls yeah yeah they just
burn in silence yeah yeah i got a guy it
would burn the guy but they gotta move
on but if the girl now gets burned yeah
it's like what so what you're better
than me now it still depends on the
friendship though yeah but even some
friendships some girls can be friends
for years and like sometimes some girls
they're just girls they're just girls
that just can't take criticism so no
matter how long you're friends with
someone yeah they were just there just
instilled that it's still going to be
something that they're going to keep
inside and just wait to just
like just
without writing them just
attack
yeah yeah you get it
okay so i'm